oh
that was great
[Music]
oh it's like they're quite live in
Boston yeah
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna do a movie
reaction today for The Equalizer time to
be upfront about a couple of things koi
he has never seen The Equalizer one I
did see this one time when I was a lot
of that back then in 2014 needless to
say the only thing I kind of remember a
little bit of action other than that I
really don't know the plot anymore
something about protecting I I is it
Dakota I forget who it is some Johnson
one of the Johnsons this will be my
first time re-watching this and I
remember walking out going it's good but
I don't remember it so and part of the
thing I want to start by the real
rejects is like re-watching to see if
this movie's still good I have
Armageddon on my list like I have a few
movies well you don't know that so
so that's my this is for me my journey
on that and this is Corey's first time
watching and if this goes well we'll
cover equalizer 2 both we have not seen
too long of an intro koi should they
leave a like they should leave a like
because this is about a quiet man living
in Boston who I assume is a
mathematician because he equalizes
things perhaps he taught good with
London should they fall somewhere page
five I was on the patreon page where you
can watch the entire reaction start to
finish you can watch our resting faces
sync up with us and then we can see what
they equalize I'm excited to see if you
like this movie I'm ready to see what
equalizes what is her name it's not
Johnson oh wait no I know which actress
it is shots is Man Apart I just
remembered
there's a little girl but I just
remember who the actress was yeah I
thought you meant the name of the model
today
I thought there was like a Johnson
actress in here and and I'm realizing
it's a different little girl yeah
there's a different little girl in this
movie yeah
oh wow this movie's deep
7 30 the most equal of times
everything balanced as they should be
left
notice these doors are not evenly shut
equalize them
but it does it's an OCD freak I remember
it now
make your hairline very equal
[Music]
I gotta cut this out it's not gonna stop
screw you guys the rest of the movie's
gonna be that two hours drama
I believe that this was a show first and
then they made the movies and then Queen
Latifah's in the show now and then they
have a part three coming up is it all
one Universe like John Wick I do not
believe so okay how's it going all right
bro what you got that it's tuna right
whole grain gluten free okay condiments
it's a bone in the tuna
potatoes are a vegetable
security guards you're going to lose
weight you got to test in one week now
you asked me to help you but if you're
not willing to apply yourself God damn
that's like a real life Denzel it's just
in 10 lessons this guy's taking out his
board life while making sure he loses
weight
I was something once you better start
being something you could have projected
my boredom under you
it's nice to see a movie in Boston
that's not about the Irish mob
you fight them well I don't remember who
he fights actually
his mom I hope it is just a bunch of
Scorsese extras
this guy runs on Mark Wahlberg schedule
gotta pray gotta wake up gotta work out
gotta sleep
I don't understand some of these
meticulous quirks I do think it's an OCD
thing
Chloe Grace Moretz
yeah thank you oh 100 Johnson
he got that fish yet
bought a little machine for making demos
I bet you're good it makes you say that
intuition cool
let me know what happens with that uh
fish
okay you picked up on her occupation I
think she might uh be an architect yeah
just saying she's probably got a hyphen
and her name you know what I'm saying a
little Terry Lynn action old man tied to
fish to the side of the boat had to roll
back to shore the fish bled in the water
Sharks game and ate the whole fish well
it's just kind of a waste isn't it oh
that's clever the old man met his
greatest adversary just when he thought
that part of his life was over he saw
himself in the fish
I like that a lot I get what you're
telling me movie
Russians
I don't think I've ever met a prostitute
really
[Laughter]
I'm from this
it's a pretty common job
You're Gonna Leave me to die I'm smoking
inhalation I'm a buck name how you gonna
pull me out of a burning building if you
can't pull a tire 20 yards
hey don't doubt yourselves on doubt
kills get up doubt kills I like his
little morsels of wisdom
come on
[Applause]
security guard
it's a smart movie because it really
gets you invested into his personality
and mindset yeah and he
he cares for everybody yeah it's really
it is and we've met the fish and I love
the old man being like I'd follow a
Trilogy this old man hooking fish
exactly it's not gonna change he's not
just like stoic and or charming he's
he's got like a full human Personality
yeah
Robert
Robert reads books like this Bobby
sharper yeah okay different Vibes though
Robbies Bobs Roberts fair enough
okay it's not professional just tell me
what you think okay wow Alina oh on your
wedding figures no Mrs Robert at home no
was there ever once he's gonna break her
heart just broke my eye I hope you
murdered her
equalized
guy who thinks he's a knight in shining
almond only thing is he lives in a world
where nights don't exist anymore he
reads a lot of apps books
convenient this list
is it called the equalizer's 100.
you'll see if you can clean things
all right
whoa call this number I send you another
one better
[Laughter]
he smells so confident
that's great
it's like what reaction is he gonna give
oh man that was so much for badass today
so in control you could smile like that
damn we're like 20 minutes in her hasn't
been an action scene it's my favorite
kind of action movies I love the tension
they're like letting build like the
lighting's doing so much heavy lifting
she's at the ICU at Shawmut someone beat
her up real good
damn this is a good movie yeah I don't
remember any of this it's too young
ten years ago yeah
oh my goodness
and she hit him back a guy called sloppy
so it's loving made an example of her I
burned one girl's face with batteries
2014 at the time when Russians were
always like bad guys in movies and stuff
you mean since 82.
that's myself
[Laughter]
I'm here about a certain girl this girl
she got a name her name's Elena I
understand it's like you're an
investment
[Laughter]
give you 9 800 dollars
Freedom Looking Americans think that you
could come into my place of business and
just buy whatever you want capitals
nine thousand dollars
one month
that's it one month
let's go
[Music]
oh he's got chills
Goosebumps it's so cool it's like
Sherlock Holmes in it he's like picking
his weakness spots
[Music]
nice tail oh
oh cool
it's been past 16 seconds dude that
shark glare of his
oh
you can see
oh 19 seconds Helena the girl you beat
half to death her life's gonna go on
yours is gonna have right here on this
funky floor over ninety eight hundred
dollars consequences I remember there
being an action scene I don't remember
it being that violent that was like at
all so intense
let me just go ahead and gut this guy
with a corkscrew of course yeah that was
gross oh I love the like the focal
points of weakness you saw across the
room and then like the timing of him
marking it and then like executing it
yeah oh that was great this guy's a
great multitasker he'd run a wonderful
YouTube channel
[Laughter]
got the timing down
testimon used to Leading that salty
stuff these are for you
I made the way oh
what happened
hit it on something stupid
[Laughter]
it's fascinating watching this back
because I remember it like fragment
images like a trailer in a way oh yeah
like Memories like that was familiar I
think there's a like there's an action
scene here don't remember what it what
happens you know my heart rate went down
take me to the Madison
look at that guy about to go with this
guy
I don't remember his name
sure is a bad guy a lot we figured two
maybe three guys kill them all that
quickly none of our informants heard
about this going down security systems
hard drive was taken
drive me to my residence uh yeah wait a
second Mr Sunshine um what do I look
like to you chauffeur Town you're a
[__] guest doing a Boston accent I
think uh something like that
I'm the one Mr Bush can calls in when
people like you I'm accountable now
listen pal I don't like your time with
me Mr pushkin's money for years I'm here
to tell you what to do nice is cool good
villain he found his equal
I'm just excited David Harbor pre-news
room is in this movie my mom had a
little accident here last night there
was a fire
I see
okay
looks like arson a little bit John you
know I got respect for your business
you understand why I'm compelled to make
this physio if I want to take over
anything there'd be nothing left to you
people
I hate you Russians they're all crazy
and you're arrogant
more reasonable
man Mr Mooney I appreciate your kindness
It's refreshing and and lets me
understand that you're not smart enough
to have done this
we pay you 15 to do business here the
additional 10 you steal we ignore we
anticipated as your people are such a
cliche
you think you are coming down to me what
I am who I am is complicated what I am
is easier I'm a threat I alter outcomes
oh geez oh damn oh damn
oh
so much more brutal that was uh that was
a lot that's a lot right
I uh
whoa
I feel like David Harbor right now it's
so unsettling about it like violent
about how uh aggressive he was what the
[__] what's that it's a message
says I'm here that guy must be so tall
[Laughter]
oh that was intense it's a great
illustration of a villain because Denzel
is so efficient and clean and Swift and
this guy's just brutally messy this
guy's like a brawler and he's telling us
he's giving us a message yeah was there
anything unusually strange about slavi
before he was murdered did he mention
the name perhaps agitated about
something who's this actress she's very
cool looking Daddy
where we might find her sorry all of our
Associates Irish Italians Armenians are
all denying any knowledge or involvement
there's Armenians in Boston some
they're all in the mob recording movies
whoever did this specialized in
I don't think it's someone we've
encountered before
it's an interesting structure we've
barely spent any time with Denzel in a
while yeah we don't really need to
because they've established them so well
and then it's like charming and then
leave again and now they're really
building up the threat it's pretty
clever it's different it's more like a
mini series it's more like a show where
you can live in an episode an episode
let's watch The Queen Latifah one now I
think it's going to be very similar I'm
sure she does such brutality
she's playing this role
I like this red dragon shot good call
oh who puts the lotion on the skin
but they're making him like so
animalistic and like
an alien threat with these wonky angles
is crazy there's like a hellish vibe to
it yeah especially with the satanic
symbolism on his body it's very subtle
someone else's clothes
what the [__]
uh
uh see you pay on time no more problems
come on let's go to the banana
hey officer whoa
I'd like to report a crime really call
9-1-1
when I got two corrupt cops right in
front of me
how'd you get that [__] number it
wasn't hard yeah it was this
pay like everybody else how did he get
that those people you took the money
from maybe you should give it back would
be the best interest of everyone
involved maybe our best interest is to
tie a cinder block around your waist and
throw you in the [__] Mystic it's a
good idea that's a terrible idea
foreign
Justice remember
I'm The Equalizer cleaning up the
streets of Boston yeah hurt more than
the beaten
sincerely zero [__] no recollection
of him cleaning up anything else I was
like I thought it was just like bad guys
this is part of the movie now the lights
come back to the movie The Sun's shining
like in the first 10 minutes when did
you last talk
I went to the hospital
yes ah nice man not black man she wanted
to know what happened to her no one saw
her did she like
damn this guy is scary terrified
oh it's so so off but
I was born in killing her just because
she lied I think she lied and because I
mean leave a message to the people that
were friends with her that you know
they're gonna find that body they're
gonna find out they're gonna have people
to send messages
man all the angles is so intense like
they really it's interesting how they
maintain a level of Gore or like
violence with both our characters so the
protagonist and antagonist but one feels
like a positive one feels like a cool
action movie The Other feels like super
Grim yeah that's a really good point and
all of his angles are so uncomfortable
like whereas all of Denzel's are cool
there's a lot of lurking in the shadows
kind of and the frames are really oh
yeah you got the security job
now gain that weight back it's time I
mean the restaurant's probably making
way more money now frankly
[Laughter]
it's kind of curious in this person
walks in the front door several minutes
off the slot arrived but never comes out
still shadowed and obscured that's how
the movie's lit it's actually accurate
another movie maybe not open there I
just said
oh move perfect
your mother give me that ring
Boston some of the worst people
it's okay Jenny
whoa crazy lighting damn
[Music]
there's some great visual language in a
lot of this
what a perfect store to work at for him
so excited to hear Denzel say Somerville
it's a Boston kid
it's like I'm saying Eagle Rock out here
it's just a little town it's exciting
hey we saw the hammer
he put
he put inventory I love the way we need
to see it that's great I wonder if it
was deleted it's way more intense it
works without scene yeah because we're
like was it probably more violent and we
did not score well with testosters
but our imagination is way more
terrifying than whatever actually not in
this movie I take it back this movie's
very graphic we're looking into a
homicide it occurred two weeks ago
Russian restaurant oh yeah I heard about
it on TV I happen to be there that night
are you aware yeah you wouldn't be here
if I wasn't
[Laughter]
I was meeting a friend it was her idea
then I guess
Sheila Saunders but she won't be any
health she wasn't there daughter had a
fever
don't you want to leave me your card
officer
must have given them all out how'd you
find me I paid cash we didn't have a
reservation how'd you find me
we need to find we who
oh that was awesome what a great scene
You're such like a buildup yeah and it's
not like it's a finale there's just a
dialogue confrontation that was
beautiful so that's why I killed her to
have a threat oh okay yeah get under his
skin that's how disposable everybody is
man that was intense more movies need
that scene where like the bad guy and
the good guy meet and it's intense yes
and they go to dinner and it's awesome
I want to know who he really is I want
to know who he's working for
still sits confidently by the window
same Diner they know he's going to be at
our roll no cheese please
is it just you are we waiting for
someone else
fans
if you really work the power lines down
there your hands wouldn't look like that
I know we got to be waiting for somebody
else
[Laughter]
respect oh I love it
here's where I could see him
I'm gonna take a little walk across the
street me and you black Denali here we
go
no way yes
nice
[Applause]
let's go
no Witnesses
[Music]
and he knows
what the hell is this guy doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes now he's got oh man that's good I
[__] love this movie
[Laughter]
laughs
if he bleeds man that book kill was
gnarly it doesn't like book stuff like
the Bourne movies and everything but I
don't think I've ever seen like a neck
snap with a book like into the table
with that crunch
great Batman scene you know what this
movie manages to do really well where I
feel like a lot of action movies fail
they managed to have a main character
who's so in control and and you trust
will handle [__] all the time yet
there's still manages to be tension
throughout yeah at no point am I not
worried but I know he's got normally
there's no tension because of that also
the wiser 3 comes out this year and I
know I'm still invested
it's pretty crazy and you're right the
juxtaposition of like control versus
brutality even though he's brutal so
interesting
oh
when did he get cut who cut him first
scrape himself by accident and all that
moving
he wouldn't go to his own house where
did he go
neither following the trail yes
oh I love this
plane ticket to Mexico two days ago he's
not going anywhere he's watching us
find him or I will bring people who care
[Music]
so you have two apartments
it's the dream one to watch the other
one checking in
somebody hit my house
cast is great
what's her name ah [__] it's really
bothering me it'll come to me it sounds
like I'm reading the credits Melissa Leo
yes yeah I consult on a few things
that's it Susan I just need to know
who this man is tell me what's going on
please
equalizing the streets
I like that I've ever done it cuts he
says something like that they cut out
all the ziggers let's keep them cool
she couldn't count
for his oh no not Robert
and not from something as trivial as a
car bomb Oh his name is actually Robert
yeah okay
similar to the other oligarchs who
jumped in bed
with funds everything gasoline weapons
girls you name it he's built an
intricate Network on both U.S coasts One
Stop Shop your friend here
is who Pushkin sends when he's got a
problem real name Nikolai kitchen oh
that's where the photos I guess it's an
explosion and everything
no no
found basically the sociopath for the
business
we kept this
it's like super clean
that was the actor's headshot
I found them yesterday
suffocated testicles blown off and
shoved down their throats
third one detective Masters hasn't shown
up for work in several days
oh he's a cop I didn't realize
I didn't realize that
one day somebody does something
do something about it because you can
because it's who you are a pain in the
sick that's the theme I know a part of
you guys
she did die okay how much recover that
wasn't
when Rocky
were you able to help him
I don't trust you Bill Pullman
came for permission
yes yes
what a good line let me read the clouds
when talking
how can I use the clothes in my disposal
to win this one right on the Russians
now
foreign
hope they all take place in Boston
it's a good question equalizing all the
streets have you ever seen the trailer
for the third one so I don't know
oh he's gonna make it look like he
killed himself and he plants in it all
that's genius
there it is
at the carbon monoxide
[Music]
love it yes that's awesome you're about
to get equalized what does it even mean
to equalize
equalized
horrible way to go I am a cop you [__]
I'll be back
this is made me question how many movies
I've seen David Harbor and if I didn't
know it was David Harper I think it's
one of those like career actors you're
like all right yeah who's in this movie
have you seen The Newsroom no okay
that's excusable wow
wow how cool is a criminal it's
profitable who's this [__] piece of
[__] new guy
that was great oh [__]
damn they did one shot that was awesome
it was so good guns down lay down lay
down with the hands behind their back
they'll do that won't they
indulge me Andre
it's not easy to do that before that was
really impressive yeah it's really
believable yeah
I was a good cop
[Music]
do the right thing
good cups
fiction
Harper's great in this too I mean I
imagine he's always been a great actor
yeah but he gets more to do than I
expect it's more than suicide I thought
it'd be like that
sir
it was Boston in that too right Black
Mass oh yeah yeah he's gotten
progressively better at the accident I
was that one scene through me but I'm
very impressed check this out
how did he get them all to get tied up
got him laying the floor at a time
you made things worse by looking for him
it's on you it's cool it's not just
burning it like most action movies
my men will find him
good I got the pace
Bono
the fake beer
he's not coming back
[Laughter]
that was amazing
you can call your boss and tell him to
shut down his operation that's not much
of an offer that's the only one you're
gonna get
When you pray for rain you got to deal
with the mud too
cool I like that famous scholar lived in
Moscow he was a humanitarian and even
though he had five beautiful children he
opened his home to a sixth okay could
have been pounded by the system from an
early age prone to violence
a lost cause stop me if you know this
one
[Laughter]
until the boy who had never felt
anything like being wanted or loved he
finally did one week later Intruders
broke into the man's house killed the
man they said some small things were
stolen things a child might steal okay I
think the boy did it and he couldn't
bear the thought that this man this good
man would do that to him would throw him
away
like a piece of land or
the man I killed your men they made
their decision I'm giving you the
opportunity to make yours
Bank you're welcome
I promise someone that I love very much
that I would never go back to being that
person
but for you
I'm going to make an exception
what do you see when you look at me
will never be this cool that was so
awesome he made him emotional they had
the heat scene they got a lot
it's funny
Senator I gotta get into politics I mean
agent Mosley please heard you found some
money today check your personal email
make sure you're sitting down when you
do
[Laughter]
wow half a billion dollars cool we're in
the wrong business you know YouTube's
just not cutting it for the half these
good shot movies earned it they've
earned it it's earned it's definitely
look away don't watch it
foreign
ER for A Man Apart
the one with the Johnson girl no man on
fire is the man of parts of Vin Diesel
damn it the other ball guys
dude he's just walking out of the
explosion
[Music]
wow they really threw down for this well
there's that setting on fire thing I was
talking about
Brick by Brick but your life for that
rules
from a call oh
unless you're here in 29.
Dad's all just got equalized all things
balanced you Glen it out when you see
him shoot him
which way
are we getting a Home Depot fight sorry
to spoil it for you
but Chan's dream location I remember any
details about the fight I've always
wanted a Home Depot fight
oh
what the hell
moved out of the way just step to the
side
oh
you just lures him into that room one at
a time
when he hit him that was risky oh
listen everybody out of here don't leave
anybody behind you can use the service
doors in the back okay go only two
people with the hostages I guess they
assumed they were just you know Home
Depot employees very clever Mr McCall I
decided to come and see you
I'll be waiting for you find the
hostages
was this pretty John Wick I think it is
some of the same stunt people too
oh is that Barbed yeah
oh what a way to go
yo he likes to kill yeah he likes to
watch
oh
Jesus Christ damn
starting in a freaking Jason Voorhees
this is so intense
oh no he's human
he brought a gun to a knife fight
[Music]
she's doing Denzel the little pipe bomb
what's it supposed to go oh is he
cauterizing the wound Maybe
nope oh Megan making a little doorknob
Bob
oh he just got arrested a little
doorknob
[Applause]
you pushed him right into the oh God
[Music]
I would love it if you actually hit the
water after all that
the big guys are always harder to take
down
especially with mustaches
I can't even see what he's doing he's
like taking blades and just chop suey in
him he's pepper cutting them
no oh
ouch
yeah
oh
it's me Mr McCall that's Ralphie
I should not leave anybody behind who's
gonna try again beautiful
[Laughter]
come on oh no
no not the buddy not his buddy he lost
all that weight can you make it to the
breaker box
40 seconds exactly
this is such a dark Warehouse
I wonder for the edit they planned this
to be 40 seconds too it's exactly 40
seconds I think earlier was actually the
28 seconds felt like about accurate I
wonder if
okay
[Applause]
oh damn no
did he know that guy was gonna be in
that room
was that nail gun nail got him in the
rain
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
cool
great looking shots damn
oh
sexy when it rains you gotta be prepared
for the mud blood Bud
hardcore dude that was crazy now that
guy knows friends is a mercenary
you should be working security not me
his training makes much more sense and
it's much scarier now
you said so many threatening things this
man can murder me
contextualizes every conversation we've
ever had I'm terrified of this man
[Music]
he goes to Russia to take out the boss
yeah oh no way
I was thinking like like 40 minutes and
like what this battery takes him out
here won't they still just keep it I was
going in my head like is that what the
sequel list they just keep coming back
from every bigger boss yeah that's like
the end of Blade he's going to Moscow to
take out the lead vampire
come to kill me
yes
what's he doing with the light
disorienting let's do the game from my
dad
peace yeah
whoa
for the second movie was a lot of fun
too I hope so because this is great yeah
I want more equalizing so much more
and by the last few days I'm gonna run
into you yeah I'm reading now oh no
when they giving myself back at the
hospital there was this
envelope my name on it
almost ten thousand dollars inside nine
thousand eight hundred roughly if
someone else told me I could be whoever
I wanted to be
Body Mind
Spirit nice remember
you got your own
thank you
and catch you around all right
oh my God they should do a spin-off with
just her focusing on her music career
the whole series but call it hit girl
about making hits hahaha
next I'll battle the sea now the sea man
those you see stories there's uh themes
they're all nautical
oh my God is he writing a book now
The Invisible Man this list is very
topical to his goals and I respect it
oh [__]
damn he's just a full-blown vigilante
now badass For Hire Denzel
Craigslist vigilante I thought it was
not as good as equalizer I see why they
went with the one they did
I wonder what the original shows like
common two
what come on
gonna do it's too late to start over
the song made for this I'm wondering
yeah we're friends because he did
Southpaw yeah which is based on M's life
but as a as a boxer Jason Blumenthal is
that Jason Blum oh that's interesting
yeah
well free blumhouse action horror would
make sense because that was brutal well
if there's no credits I mean if they're
if Amazon is recommending this watch The
Mask it just means there's no post
credit no post credit well
um I mean we said a lot during the
reaction but koi take it away for your
first time watching what did you think
uh that was whichever came first
inspired the hell out of the other with
John Wayne yeah I don't know which one
came first I'll look it up right now it
was a hell of a chicken
uh man she was rad
um I loved that it was
um it trusted the audience to be
ponderous and also to be brutal and then
go back and forth I love the lighting I
love the pacing I loved it was like
almost
um over the top of the lighting at first
but then like it set the tone of the
movie really well I really loved the
framing there's a lot of shots of the
bad guy that are disorienting on purpose
that make you just uncomfortable and you
don't realize why you're so
uncomfortable you just have this like uh
and uh I think that really is
beautifully juxtaposed with all the
moving shots and the emotionality of
Denzel's character because they cut to
his eyes a lot and that gives you you
the like ability to like lean into the
character and I was saying at the very
beginning the you have to cast really
well to do the extreme close-ups they do
I didn't realize the theme of the movie
was gonna be like looking into the soul
of Denzel and he's got these great like
shark eyes where he does look lost not
sad but lost and they kept making that a
a way to make you endeared to him as
opposed to the villains so the brutality
he was just brutal as a bad guys but
like it was the fire with fire thing
that made you love him I really this was
a sensational action thriller check this
out what do we got none of the movies
influence each other
how
they this phone only came out a few
months before is that crazy this is
Armageddon Deep Impact yeah isn't that
crazy how like there's somebody's there
are similar lines to draw wow like
they're so different enough in an
execution in style but there's a lot of
similarities yeah between like Russian
bad guys dead wife pass coming back back
into the field yeah there's it's
thinking I'm back but with the equalizer
it is funny how but he's like from
government in in John Wicks from like
fantasy Hitman yeah like that's a little
bit more they both have a fantasy world
uh but this is this is uh I mean they're
very different it wasn't cool to see
them pair up oh Angela Perry she's the
Caspian stuff yeah this is this is crazy
yeah you would think that there might be
but they actually came out the same year
that's incredible that was so good I
can't believe those come out the same
year and now three is coming out the
year four came out for John Wick they've
kept going
so good that's true except John works at
four but like I mean Denzel's been busy
being awesome well so is Keanu but that
was that was so good what'd you think
for an accidental uh not remembering I
mean I really didn't remember I I would
the only time I remembered a couple of
things were was like oh yeah Chloe Grace
Moretz so I kept thinking is not Johnson
Fanny I can't get her name
this has been such a journey
I'm like Ashley Johnson from uh
voiceovers and The Last of Us she kind
of looks like a Fanning what is her name
Dakota fan yeah Fanning's in A Man Apart
amazing man a man of fire my god there
was like an era of those kind of movies
so
um a Man on Fire which
um that's a fear such a banger good
choice that's another movie about as in
Denzel like trying to like who I I kind
of just got revenge on something I think
no I think she's kidnapped and he's
trying to save her oh okay but it's
another one with the him and a little
white girl hey let's watch all the
dimensions
this second one does as well if this one
does well in the second one does well
let's move over to the saves White Girl
Movement is in that train movie they do
with Chris Pine is Chris Pine the little
white he's a little white girl and
that's an eye I have not seen that
little white girl movie have you seen I
haven't seen it yeah I've seen pieces
but not tonight I've missed a lot of
Denzel actually I haven't seen like I
was moved I haven't seen safe house safe
house I've seen half of and loved it I
was working in a movie theater then so I
like saw it in pieces where I'd like
walk in and be like Ryan Reynolds and
leaf there's another one called out of
time I've not seen that one the remake
of taking a Pelham One Two Three haven't
seen that
um equalizer two uh equalizer two tinsel
has like there's a lot of like Denzel
action movies and then Liam took his
jobs yeah but I feel like Denzel really
kept bringing because like this is
my memory told me it was just a
straightforward action movie which is
brutal which it is it's a
straightforward action movie by plot but
the execution around it had a little
more Soul than I was expecting I recall
at all like I just I thought it was just
a typical like yeah he's I don't
remember anything about him like helping
out the neighborhood which feels a tad
a tad like it didn't need to be in this
no that's how you like them otherwise
he's just killing people for that girl
you got to save the neighborhood it
seemed like if it was it didn't really
serve the plot overall it's happening
from Boston I love the neighborhood I
like it I like that it's here it didn't
seem like it really was fully fleshed
out it was a bigger part of like him him
helping the guy as a security guard the
next step is to help help stop people
for like 15 minutes
maybe that's the show between Latifah
well I feel like the original show that
this is based on if I were to take a
guess oh that would be what what has
happened and accelerates into boss
fights yeah like they needed a main plot
to focus on which was you know the whole
thing with Chloe Grace Moretz of the
show is like helping the town out yeah
yeah I could see that yeah I still like
it in here it just it kind of seemed
like oh it was setting up to become more
and then it it doesn't because we got
busy because we got to go kill that big
bad yeah what was the bad guy's name did
we check was it Kieran is not he's not
uh his name didn't pop up uh so I I
don't know who it was okay but he was
great he was great really great
formidable villain I did feel like he
lost some of his menacing threat towards
the finale the finale did feel the only
time I didn't love the pacing this is
the third act had a little bit of me
being like okay I've really enjoyed the
intensity to this point and now there's
a couple times where I was like this
feels like they're drawing out the
suspense for the sake of it as opposed
to like with uh the drive the rest had I
mean yeah yeah that's true I would agree
with that because I I did I do wish that
they kept the villain truly menacing by
the end to the point where he did feel
like a formidable match yeah because
that heat scene both of them the one the
one on the stairway is like one of the
best action threat scenes I've seen yeah
and then I enjoyed the dinner quite a
bit because that definitely was heat
like that was really great there's great
acting between this between the two of
them they know how to bounce off of each
other and play the cat and mouse game
really well and I like the pairing when
you take that first scene where they
meet and then that second scene it's
really cool to watch the juxtaposition
and how the Dynamics have flipped around
yeah that's really cool what happened to
Haley what was that girl's name she was
in um she died
no but she was also in that Uh Oh you
mean the actors like the actual actress
I thought you meant uh yeah
it was very important and very brutal
yeah that was one of my favorite shot
scenes because they kept like cutting
outside the room to make you like Ah
that's like right in the neighborhood
too yeah feel it in the room no she was
in that cowboy it could happen in your
neighborhood if you go to selfie you
might get strangled it should happen
anywhere man but no she uh she was in
that Chris Pratt cowboy movie uh
Magnificent Seven yeah and then I
haven't seen her anything since don't
remember her or not yeah
I think it was yeah oh man he's great
make more movies
I like Southpaw quite a bit but I
haven't seen I guess I haven't seen some
of his other work because southpaws I
think really slept on I haven't seen
southpaw
it's crazy to see the trajectory of when
you go to training day which was a David
ayerscript and an Anton fuquan movie and
then the directions they've taken yeah
Dave there has tried recapturing the
magic of training day yeah and Anton
Fuqua was like I'll make anything I'm an
action director I'm gonna make
everything over there
which is not training you know he's just
like I'm an action director here on out
I'm making action movies
and like Anton except for like Southpaw
I guess but there's like an element oh
there's actually yeah there's an action
element but like you're right there
definitely went other ways and David air
was like End of Watch and I'm gonna try
to make training days
gonna get a full stomach tattoo for me
why we don't know oh yeah that's right
and no one saw the movie but he got a
tattoo for real right I remember that
that's right yeah oh my God he's got a
career man I'm sure he's incredible but
that's also him not trying to make a
David air movie David like that action
they both need to do good action movies
it would be cool to see them re-team
again yeah because of that but I I did
well the first movie I ever saw of Anton
Fuqua was a movie called The Replacement
Killers not The Replacements Keanu
Reeves Replacements is the football
movie The Replacement Killers is chow
young fat I think that was his first
American lead film it's cool it's a cool
ass movie uh him and Mira servino and
Michael Rooker uh yeah that's a and that
was the first movie I think Anton fuco
made that was like a hit and then he did
Training Day following whoa so yeah
sometimes you guys are like you've not
seen any movies
yeah it's so funny if you're like you
haven't seen this it's like hey look at
the 4 000. there's like millions of
movies sorry we missed the one you love
a lot which is why we're watching it for
you but like there's so many movies
um but yeah I thought overall that this
movie was so much better than I expected
it to be I didn't remember being
impressed by like I don't know I watch
movies a little more lazily back in the
day 10 years ago can watch [__] right so
watching it now I I appreciate it so
much more about it that the the the the
um the actual efforts they made with
unveiling and getting to know who this
character is whose name is Robert oh who
getting to know who Robert is throughout
the course of this film and underst and
they actually lean into the fact that
you know there's a part of him that
wants to kill he's a killer yeah you
want to do it they don't need some Spiel
of like I know who you really are Robert
you're a killer like you don't need to
say that it was kind of neat to kind of
get that conversation from attraction
from through action and from the
government person who's like okay she's
like you you this is who you do yeah go
be him go be that person you were born
to be you're a killer like she doesn't
say it but that's essentially that
dialogue that you get in every action
movie of this guy is you're a killer
just admit it you know and but they play
into it with the action when he watches
them like he likes to watch them die uh
there's there is a violence that he is
drawn to and I think Chloe Grace Moretz
is actually I I didn't I didn't remember
until like moments before like oh yeah
she's in this movie uh I think Chloe
Grace Moretz is really good in this film
it's kind of cool how she can go from
being like hit girl to this person yeah
the Innocence played as well as her like
insane violence place like some people
can't do the foul-mouthed you know blah
blah and then also scene innocence and
she nails that and that's not an easy
role to go from like you have to be so
sympathetic for her that you're like
yeah you kill all those people like he
should put himself In Harm's Way with
this girl he knows from a diner yeah and
I also really like that everything he
did was so detail-oriented like the the
details he gives to help people the
details about the guy's hands the the
details of looking for weakness like his
ability to curate a room felt very
plausible like they gave you rules in
this movie that I'm really excited for
it to be a series because I'm excited to
see him like use things so it was like a
Sherlock beats like Jackie Chan like how
will I use this weapon in this space but
he also uses it for like logic like the
hands thing that wasn't weaponized but
it was showing you how much he notices I
love that yeah and then the eyes he took
my point yeah I was gonna say I was
thinking my head like when he's done
talking I'm gonna say Sherlock Holmes
he said exactly
I think there was a warehouse scene I've
always wanted to see Jackie Chan fight
in a warehouse I had pretty sure he's
done that um has he yeah I'm sure he
should watch a Jackie Chan fish probably
shoot a lot of those actions he's done
in a warehouse in order to accomplish
that I always think about Jackie Chan in
warehouses maybe I've had a subconscious
memory yeah
I'm pretty sure he's done that yeah the
the action itself was really well done
and I I do I'm trying to think of a
point that we didn't say during the
reaction we talked a lot hopefully
people are okay with that I mean yeah
there's some like points to that had to
be made
um okay so we covered the action drama
casting the Oh The Supporting Cast was
really good too A lot of the time
a movie like this you'll go
I'm kind of bored when it's not Denzel
but not have that but I actually was
really endeared to the rest of the cast
as well I thought the villain was really
great A lot of times they botched the
villain David Harbor crushed as a
supporting [__] David Harbor at times
have seemed a little bit like a little
melodramatic preachy when he was saying
some stuff about being a cop well oh I
know what what it was that I wanted to
say was what to your point about
watching how he likes to sort of mentor
and instill good values and stuff
that makes it believable when he is
doing the Vigilante stuff because it's
not just self-serving in him wanting to
be you know like you buy into it that
he's really doing this out of a place of
good yeah because you see that he likes
to still help people out mentally first
and emotionally and he always gives him
a chance to be better yeah exactly uh so
I think that's really that that was a
part that I thought really aided the
film and brought a little bit more to
this is what this movie really is is a
lot of other action movies we've seen
just a little more just more fleshed out
and thought up yeah than your typical
action movie like it has it's kind of
like how I likened my experience of them
have you seen the movie Nobody
[Music]
yeah yes I was like okay yeah there's a
this is a genre in and of itself there's
a lot of tropes but it's more fleshed
out and that's what I would say here is
it is a lot of the genre tropes that
we've seen especially and and like
structurally but they mess with the
structure a little bit on where to focus
and they they actually developed the
character of of Robert Moore than you
would normally get they kind of do that
all around yeah everyone gets a little
bit more time and every every scene gets
a little bit more patience yeah even the
Trope like abused girl that is gonna go
you know get Justice for that's a Trope
in and of itself but I actually wasn't
bothered by that Trope normally I am a
little like and this trip is a little
Annoying and repetitive but this time
around it actually didn't bother me
because they did want to disgust you
like there were moments I was like
repulsed like some of the dialogue about
it like they didn't lean sometimes
showing like actual assaults yeah yeah
but they let it be like really
uncomfortable like just showing the guy
in the limo was enough for me I was like
oh okay like they did a good job making
your opposal without making it
gratuitous about that subplot because I
usually can't watch that stuff yeah
exactly that kind of stuff does bother
me because it does become like a Trope
that I I'm sick of seeing in movies and
it's it's just like they lean too much
on it but they actually really did a
good job on painting the relationship
with Chloe Grace Moretz and Denzel
Washington uh in the early Parts like
when they're walking on the bridge and
stuff like that like those scenes I
thought were really well done they did
such a great job
before their first action scene uh yeah
you mentioned it was like 20 minutes in
and like I also love that he had a
protocol like how they even the line of
dialogue establishes their relationship
and her breaking it and that escalating
and all those things and then yeah it's
like 20 minutes in until there's even
action but there's been so much like
verbal action there's been so much like
tension yeah you know what I mean good
choice of music all around yep um I
can't wait to watch it so so excited I'm
I can't wait I don't don't look up the
runs I didn't know David Harper was in
this one I'm excited to see who's in the
next one I don't know Bill Pullman
Melissa Leo like this cast was stacked
I'm excited to be like who's 2018
equalizer it was a surprisingly big cast
considering I researched David Harbor
for interviews I did not remember
equalizer and I'm so excited to see what
like pops up for the next one and it
must have done well because the third
one's this year uh yeah they're really
spread apart
the second one second when he has hair
look at the poster what oh now it's
getting real that's not my equalizer no
look at that man's hat I don't trust it
oh looks like it goes somewhere oh well
don't read it oh no equalizer one is
five stars uh um out of 57 000 reviews
crap out of 57 000 reviews it's only
four and a half
so clearly clearly a dip in quarterly
as we learned with Kung Fu Panda 2 which
had a lesser rating it's clearly a
lesser film yeah watch us watch out this
is the one
it's about family oh it's and fuqua's
back that's exciting I was always afraid
I'm pretty sure he's done all I'm pretty
sure he did equalizer three as well I
just get worried
because when directors change it you
know sometimes oh he is back for that is
he back for equalizer three let's find
out what's he been doing
yeah he's bald he's back to being bald
back to the crit back to the baldness
all right guys that's exciting for all
three that's what I want to hear well
guys what did you think about The
Equalizer I can't wait to watch the
second one and to do that we need you to
like subscribe comment let us know which
is your favorite of the equalizers and
if you're Denzel let us know if the
third one's any good yeah and if you're
a Denzel please I would not like to run
into Home Depot but you seem like a nice
guy guys
falcoi and um hey let's do a patron of
the day shout out let's I know Adelia
she's a sweetie everyone knows Adelia so
shout out to Delia she is like The
Equalizer of our YouTube channel she
really is actually she's the perfect
person to shout out for this Adelia
Chamberlain in case you didn't hear that
depending on the edit you are The
Equalizer of the YouTube Community
you're everywhere you're a force of good
you're a force of being equal and you're
a force of being everywhere on these
internet streets making sure they're
clean and safe also for helping me
figure out how to run a Discord which is
like equalizing these streets can you
tell us why he's named equalizer let us
know your subtext uh also thank you for
being a patron uh you're an absolute
Delight every interaction we've had a
new interneting has been wonderful and
the opposite of the violence that we
just witnessed matter in person once she
was a total dear she really is
everywhere like I just did an interview
for a podcast for this other thing and
then I was talking with one of the
people who helped us running and they're
like oh do you know dealing in chamber
let's just start working with
she's always around and always helping
and a lot of times she used to do a lot
of stuff just rather kindness of her
heart incredible obviously that you
finally got a job doing it Delia love
you so much and uh you've been part of
our patreon pretty much since the
beginnings and you've been in for years
now so thank you so much for being you
talk to you all soon
[Music]